If you're a student of history you probably know that ideas come at some point
of time and the practical use may come at a much later point of time. An
excellent example of that is Boolean algebra, which
was invented at the turn of the century
as a pure mathematical exercise by George Boole.
Now, Boolean algebra is the basis for pretty
much anything and everything we do with computers. The concept of virtualization
also had its beginning way back in time. It started with IBM VM 370 in the
60s and the early 70s. And the intent. And IBM VM370 was to give
the illusion to every user on the computer as though the computer is theirs.
That was the vision and it was also a vehicle for binary support for legacy
applications that may run on older versions of IBM platforms. And then of
course we had the microkernels that we
have discussed in the earlier course module
which surfaced in the 80s and early 90s. That in turn gave way to extensibility
of operating systems in the 90s. The Stanford project SimOS in the late
90s, laid the basis for the modern resurgence of
virtualization technology at the operating system level and in fact, was the
basis for VMware. Even the specific ideas we're
going to explore in this course module. Through Xen and
VMware, are papers that date back to the early 2000s. They were proposed
from the point of view of supporting application mobility, server consolidation,
collocating, hosting facilities, distributed web services.
These are all sort of the
candidate applications for which Xen and
VMware while positioning this virtualization technology.
And now today, virtualization has taken
off like anything. Why the big resurgence
today? Well, companies want a share of everybody's pie. One of the things that
has become very obvious, is the margin for device making companies in terms of
profits, is very small. And everybody wants to get into providing services for
end users. This is pioneered by IBM and others are following suit as well.
So the attraction with virtualization technology is that companies can now
provide resources with complete performance isolation
and bill each individual user separately. And
companies like Microsoft, Amazon, HP, you
name it, everybody's in this game wanting
to provide computing facilities through their data centers to a wide diversity
of user communities. So that it's a win-win situation for both the users
that do not want to maintain their own computing infrastructure and constantly
upgrading them. And the companies like IBM that has a way of providing
these resources on a rental basis, on a utility basis, to the user
community. You can see the dots connecting up from the extensibility studies of
the 90s like the spin and exokernel, to virtualization today, that is providing
computational resources, much like we depend on
utility companies to provide electricity and water.
In other words, virtualization technology has made computing very much
like the other utilities that we use to such as electricity and water and
so on. And that's the reason why there's a huge resurgence in
the user virtualization technology in all the data centers across the world.